i also watched uh all of my shoulder
i'll see you watching adam i said i said
i was going to all of it
one entrance round of course
thank you after after i said i would and
everyone was like connor's not going to
watch it
and then there's a bunch of comments
that are like i hope connor doesn't
watch it because i know he's gonna hate
it because did you hate it
no well i liked it wow i like it okay
okay
honestly yeah it's really good um
i can see why people think i would hate
it yeah because the first episode i was
like
all right
weird champ
i mean listen listen
the way it starts is [ __ ] weird right
because you know he gets he gets isakai
does you do because it's the first
isakai right that's all i knew about it
was it was the only thing i knew about
the show is that it was the first i i
feel like whenever connor hears isa kill
i like
flashbacks of like me talking like yeah
basically basically
and so you know i went into this with an
open mind i didn't read any reviews i
didn't watch any videos i didn't i don't
know anything about my shocker tensei
right yeah everyone knows that everyone
hypes it up yeah that's like okay i'll
watch it you know
be me right first episode right i'm
watching this thing yeah and he gets
issac as a as a toddler first thing he
does is he starts like admiring like the
woman's tits and i'm like
oh [ __ ]
this is the show that everyone's hyping
up
this is it
this is it he doesn't he didn't just
admire the tits he like makes a shrine
out of like one of their panties right
yeah so the whole first like two
episodes it was just him being like an
insect
i completely forgot that
that was on one episode of just
and i was like are we seriously just
gonna watch
a guy
another show where an in-cell just gets
rewarded with like a massive [ __ ] in the
new universe bestowed confidence uh
magical powers the most op guy and never
has to overcome the fact that he has
really unhealthy views towards women and
sex and everything yeah but this one was
good because i felt like they he
actually at least somewhat
learned that hey maybe maybe the way i
viewed women was kind of [ __ ] up in
the past yeah and i was like
holy [ __ ]
it can be done and they can do it not
only was this the first this guy but it
was the first self-realized insult on
top of that it was a good show and i was
like i was like this is great this is
fantastic because not only was the world
building amazing i was really i was
really like into the world i loved all
the characters you know even the parents
who they usually could have just been
like oh it's just [ __ ] parents i was
really surprised i filled everything up
yeah i was really surprised when the
parents were just characters because
normally you you see like anime parents
are just like half the time they're not
even [ __ ] there yeah you know and i
remember watching when they are there
you can't see their eyes yes i was
remember like watching because i'm like
so used to like isaikai speed running
this [ __ ] right which like he gets
transported he starts like getting the
girl starts beating up the dudes i don't
know i'm like five episodes into my
shogu tence i'm like what the [ __ ] he's
still with the parents what the [ __ ] is
going on what's what's going on and then
i realized wait a minute
i'm actually getting invested in the the
family dynamic and the family story and
stuff like really is like the the slow
cooker obviously guys whereas everything
else is just like a microwave you know
can i explore one minor plot point it's
not a big deal it's really not big deal
but you spoil it
the moment i knew the show was built
different
really was the
sickness you're not watching episode six
or seven it just starts and it's like
the first thing that happens is it's
like normal family life is like the
husband has cheated on the wife with the
maid yeah and she's pregnant and i'm
like
what the [ __ ] is this show doing like
what the [ __ ] is going on there was like
a whole point where he was like our 10
year old protagonist was defusing this
jerry springer episode and i'm like i'm
like what is happening in the show
what is it like what do i say sakai or
this is great yeah
and then and then they actually get into
like world building later on and it's
amazing yeah i mean what i like about it
is that it does take that time to like
build up [ __ ] with like all this like
jerry springer [ __ ] just to say like hey
dad's kind of an [ __ ] as well he can
do he can do [ __ ] bad things you know
he ain't the perfect human being and
then like it helps it just like it all
plays a part into like his journey i
guess and i think the biggest down point
was you finish the first season you're
like this this the story hasn't even
begun yeah i thought i missed an episode
or something it ended i was looking
because i thought i'm on episode 11. it
must be twelve because it ended so
abruptly yeah oh yeah i was like oh
where is it
it's episode 12.
and then i was starting on the new
season i was sex i mean that that i had
one less episode you had a hit on me
i've only seen first season sex scene is
amazing yeah the second season is really
good second season where is where you
get so much of the payoff
of what was like the world building
that's built up from the first season
yeah i would be quite annoyed if i
watched it and season two wasn't out
because i think yeah i feel blue yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it was a great show
like again like i wanna i wanna i can't
give credit enough but the fact that
they actually like just did something
different did something different and it
and it worked and the fact that this is
like the first isakai which makes me
like really concerned yes why did they
not take the good parts of this [ __ ] so
like what i can't understand is how they
take this concept of like the main guy
being an incel right yeah that's what he
is right i'm gonna keep saying it i i
absolutely hate these characters as well
yeah right because what's up uh correct
technically the light novels were like
re-zero and like yeah i was okay yeah i
was i was going to correct him
afterwards so it's not the first isekai
but it's one of the most prominent
isekai's that popularized a lot of these
okay
why
why when okay so let's say this is like
one of the first big ones right if
everyone is trying to take from this why
do they take all the worst assets
right
because each kind of me is like like i
said earlier it's just dudes who like
don't have to ever like address the fact
that they were shitty in the life before
and they just get a free do-over where
they get everything done for them yeah i
mean it's it's weird seeing like because
it was weird watching this after
watching so many isakai that have been
inspired by this show because with most
genres you have like the progenitor
right the thing that popularized a lot
of the tropes and by the time you watch
it by the time you watch that one right
you you've already seen all the tropes
before so you're like well this just
feels dated now like i like i don't get
why everyone hyped this thing up in the
first place because by the time you see
it everyone's already
done all the tropes differently and
better yeah right yeah but with
mishokudense it's like
so many so many stories just missed the
point of why
the isakai is the way it is you know why
is it an issue in the first place well
it's because
he's transported to another world to
give himself another chance at life and
a lot of stories took that as just oh
let's just put this kind of fantasy
world and just disregard the fact that
he had a previous life you know that's
just
there's like there's so many subtle
things about michoacan tensei as a story
that i feel just got
lost over time yeah in like the
different iterations of ecco that came
after it that's not that's not to say
there's there's not other east kai shows
that's come after it that's haven't been
good but like
it's it seems like yeah they're a dime a
dozen yeah it's yeah oh yeah like the
fact that he had to sorry to go jordan
yeah it just seems like so many stories
just took the surface level elements of
this story without really thinking about
why those elements were there in the
first place this is like
maybe re-zero did this a little bit but
not to the same extent but like this is
the only other easter egg that i've
watched i'm sure there are others have
done it where like he actually had to
like deal with the trauma and fears that
he had in his pr past life carried over
into this one yeah because like let's
say you come into this new life right
and you were scared of snakes you're not
gonna be magically not scared of snakes
you've got the same brain right like
he's still scared of going outside i
like that they had to deal with that
yeah yeah like i love that he had to
work through all of his issues of course
i wanted the plot to go ahead and i
wanted him to like become op and like
kill everything and become the giga chad
yeah but but i also wanted to see him
actually have to work through the [ __ ]
you wanted it to be believable when it
happens right yeah and it's so much
better pay off when you get to see that
yeah absolutely because like i was also
at the point where i was like when's the
i'm enjoying this but when's the plot
gonna happen and then i've slowly come
to realize that whenever an episode is
labeled turning point i'm just like pack
like [ __ ] put your seat belts on boys
because some some [ __ ] is gonna go down
like and i've heard from like like novel
readers that they're just like oh just
wait till you get like to turning point
four or five or something i'm like
that's turning point five what what is
going on
so good basically just a drift course
i love shows that are confident in their
world you know and like they don't need
the characters to be the world yeah it's
like they they the world lives
independently from the characters it's
like you're just you just we just happen
to be following some characters in this
world that's interesting we could follow
any of the characters and you still have
a great time i honestly i'll give it
like nine out of ten so far because i i
feel i feel like a proud father
i love it i love it
honestly it's so good like if you're
like me and you're so done with isakai
i'd give this one a shot it is genuinely
worth it when's this episode coming out
yeah uh
hold on probably the end of the month
right end of the month end of the month
february i think early first week of
february first week of february why
what's up
the first week of every year all right
yeah that's why i gave me show content
semi anime of the year
i just didn't want to spoil that
no i mean i i understand i feel like
yeah i mean i haven't watched like odd
taxi or anything like that yet but yeah
i mean i was watching it and i'm like
god damn it's doing everything right
yeah i don't know i can't complain about
anything yeah i mean the only thing i
put it above that was arcane uh as
as the best show of this year it's been
zero days
literally
okay okay okay okay movies i don't know
arcade's pretty damn good though okay
arcane's pretty damn good um but yeah i
mean that's uh yeah i'm i'm i'm i'm so
[ __ ] happy i'm so [ __ ] happy about
that it's it's like when your son
finally starts getting an interesting
football like this little gratification
feels like oh
you're happy i like what if i came in
there guns blazing and [ __ ] can't i
honestly thought you wouldn't like it
because why why'd you think that because
like a lot of the characters like i said
before they are well written characters
but a lot of them are like very tropey
you know very awesome
very tropey but i still think like
they're well-written characters
um but i just i just i just thought
you'd look at that and just be like not
a [ __ ] cinderella with like red hair
i mean she was annoying yeah yeah
she was probably my least favorite
character yeah out of all the characters
yeah i felt like you know it's it is
hard to look past the trope sometimes i
didn't really like the main character
much actually i didn't really like him
as well well i i kind of liked but i
understand why he's not i don't think
his intention was to make him likeable
yeah i actually think who's the
character i probably the character i
liked the most actually was the spur i
love
yeah
he's sick like you said i like the
languages that they actually spoke
languages i know right that was cool
yeah that was really refreshing yeah for
once we were like they speaking a
foreign language because they're always
just speaking japanese finally
because i remember when they were
speaking i'm just like when are they
going to switch to japanese it's just
like world building man they just
make sure like invest in this place and
then you know it pays off when he he
learns how to speak these languages yeah
oh my god oh my god this is what it's
like to learn a language
in a reasonable boundaries like the real
world it's like the real world holy [ __ ]
who would have [ __ ] thought
i have so much of an appreciation
appreciation for that knowing what he
went through to learn
this is one of those
shows where i'm actually glad it's a
light novel before it's an anime or
anything because i think that it's
really going to benefit from
being in uh like a long form written
yeah so you can hash out the details
they can really get like the world set
because you know sometimes when shows
come this big right they kind of get to
the point we're like oh we gotta we
gotta get the seasons out come on yeah
it's the hot [ __ ] come on we gotta
finish it yeah so i'm hoping that
doesn't happen i hope the anime because
i'm not going to read the light novels
because the anime is so good why would i
yeah i mean like the anime is so good
the production values were like insane
yeah um like some of some of the
animations too the jump from season one
to two was definitely noticeable i know
yesterday it got better like it looked a
lot crisper yeah
i mean it's just it's just an all-around
amazing production watch watch the sugar
tension watch my show
i'll definitely have to watch season two
i've been talking about it for [ __ ]
ever and i'm like so so [ __ ] funny
right now i'm happy i'm happy you know
what connor maybe i'll play
i'll do something you like this time
i'll just
count the exact runtime of my show
that's how many hours
that seems fair all right when this
episode is i'll i'll play a place with
you there we go there we go there we go
because titan has fallen
i've got a second channel now guys and
uh we've all got a second channel that
we upload to right
the guard challenge is going to turn
down april i uploaded every other day on
that channel and every other day you
know [ __ ] me